I am Tyler wios and I'm Cameron wios we
are the co-founders of Gemini Gemini is
a cryptocurrency exchange and custodian
this is going to be a talk for the
network state conference the fundamental
problem we face is a legacy regulatory
system that is both incapable of
identifying Bad actors like FTX and
focusing on attacking good actors so
Tyler and I we we got involved in
Bitcoin in 2012 and we realized that in
order for this technology to go to the
next level you needed safe regulated
onramps and so I think it's uh about 8
years ago to this day and we Now operate
I think in 70 plus countries we have I
think almost 100 assets and creating an
on-ramp into this Frontier similar to
how in the '90s when people are getting
connected in the internet they had to be
onboarded but it was all about getting
that you know first 100 million people
onto the internet and once you do that
then the companies like your
amazon.com's can can really start to get
really interesting maybe we can talk
about regulation how's the US government
doing uh not not well there's no there's
no clear framework or guidance or rules
of the road when you don't have Clarity
it's very hard to build innovation in
the free market is the best regulator
why are they doing this why are they
attacking something that's so good what
crypto does is it takes away power from
traditional power centers it's close to
like a hundred Regulators you've got to
deal with you have to have a huge legal
department raise a lot of money for that
huge compliance Department we are
notching up some wins and I think we're
going to keep winning all Explorers and
Builders and Pioneers have been attacked
by The Establishment over history this
is not new we're building a better
parallel Financial system that's fairer
the GTI quote is is first they ignore
you then they laugh at you then they
fight you then you win
and we're very much in the fight phase
and it's it's really important to remind
ourselves that that's where we are it's
important to keep you know fighting the
good fight and and we have to push back
and people who are pushing back are
winning awesome thanks apy thanks apy
great shaty